THOSE WERE EXAMPLES OF DEMOCRATS
THIS PAST YEAR QUESTIONING
REACHED ANOTHER NEW LOW.
IN RESPONSE TO PRESIDENT TRUMP'S
EMPHASIS ON SAYING
"MERRY CHRISTMAS," "NEWSWEEK" ON
THE NAZIS STOLE CHRISTMAS TO
PRESIDENT'S RECENT USE OF THE
PHRASE MERRY CHRISTMAS.
>> THIS IS A LINE THAT WE HAVE
HEARD FROM DONALD TRUMP MANY,
MANY TIMES.
THIS IS DOG WHISTLE TO THE BASE
BECAUSE NO ONE HAS EVER STOP
WHISTLE.
PHRASE.
JOINING ME NOW WITH REACTION,
CHRIS SCALIA, AND FOX NEWS RADIO
HOST TODD STARNES, AND AUTHOR
AND HIS ATTORNEY DANIELLE
McLAUGHLIN.
I'VE GOT TO GO TO YOU FIRST ON
THIS.
AS AN ATTORNEY, MAKE AN    AN AC
AS AN ATTORNEY, MAKE AN    AN AS
AS AN ATTORNEY, MAKE AN    AN AE
FOR IMPEACHMENT OF
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
>> IS YOU AND I BOTH KNOW,
DAVID, THE POLITICAL PROCESS.
>> David: BUT IT REQUIRES A
CHARGEABLE CRIME.
>> A HIGH CRIME OR A
MISDEMEANOR.
YOU WOULD SEE IN A CRIMINAL
OFFENSE, WE NEED HALF OF THE
HOUSE, TWO-THIRDS OF THE SENATE,
EVEN IF THE DEMOCRATS TAKE BACK
THE HOUSE IN 2018, I THINK
THERE'S A PRETTY LOW CHANCE THAT
WILL HAPPEN.
>> David: TODD?
THE MEDIA HAS IMPEACH HIM
ALREADY, HAVEN'T THEY?
I MEAN, DON LEMON, WHO I HAVE
KNOWN FOR YEARS, SAYS IT'S A DOG
WHISTLE.
>> LET ME SAY SOMETHING ABOUT
DON LEMON.
QUITE FRANKLY, CNN.
THEIR ENTIRE NETWORK IS A DOG
WHISTLE FOR RACE BAITING
ANTI-TRUMP BIGOTS.
I MEAN, IT IS 24/7.
THEY REALLY BELIEVE THAT
MERRY CHRISTMAS IS A DOG
THINK THE WORDS "HO HO HO" WOULD
BE CALLED FOR.
HIS CHRISTMAS INCLUSIVE REALLY
TRUE?
YOU DON'T HEAR THEM TALKING
ABOUT RAMADAN BEING INCLUSIVE.
THIS IS ABOUT MARGINALIZING
CHRISTIAN CHRISTIANITY.
AND PRESIDENT TRUMP SAID THE
WORDS, WE ARE GOING TO START
PEOPLE AGAIN, IS THAT I
UNDERSTAND THE TRUE MEANING OF
CHRISTMAS.
JESUS IS THE REASON FOR THE
SEASON.
THAT WAS THE MESSAGE THAT THE
PRESIDENT WAS TRYING TO CONVEY.
BECAUSE YOUR FATHER, A STRICT
ON FIRST AMENDMENT ISSUES,
UNCONSTITUTIONAL ISSUES, YOU
ON 20 SCALIA, WHAT DO YOU SAY?
>> I'M NOT SURE OF THE WAR OF
WHICH HE EXPRESSES CONCERNS
ABOUT A NARROWING SPACE FOR
ORIGINALIST, AND HE BELIEVED THE
CONSTITUTION SHOULD BE
INTERPRETED ACCORDING TO ITS
USUAL PUBLIC MEANING AND IT WAS
PRETTY CLEAR TO HIM THAT
ORIGINAL PUBLIC MEANING AND
TRADITION AND EARLY PRACTICES IN
AMERICA THAT IT WAS TOTALLY OKAY
FOR POLITICIANS AND THE PEOPLE
IN THE PUBLIC SQUARE TO MAKE
AND MY FATHER WAS CONCERNED THAT
THAT UNDERSTANDING WAS CHANGING
AND THE ROOM FOR PUBLIC --
FORWARD EXPRESSIONS OF RELIGION
THE PUBLIC SQUARE WAS GETTING
SMALLER AND SMALLER, AND NO
SMALL PART BECAUSE THE
SUPREME COURT'S OWN OPINIONS
WITH WHICH HE OFTEN DISAGREE DID
NOT FRONT.
>> David: DANIELLE, LOOKING AT
THIS FROM WHAT CHRIS JUST SAID,
CERTAIN WAY, OR OFFENSIVE TO
HATE IS PROTECTED SPEECH,
OFFENSIVE SPEECH OR OFFENSE IS
NOT REQUIRED.
BUT THAT DOESN'T RISE TO
CHARACTER ACCORDING TO SOME
WOULD DISAGREE WITH HIM.
IT.
>> I KNOW THAT YOU ARE A
JUST --
>> David: I'M A SUPPORTER OF
THE CONSTITUTION FIRST.
WOULD BE BENEATH OUR POLITICAL,
IN THIS CASE, THE PRESIDENT'S
OPPONENTS IN WASHINGTON.
>> SURE.
THE ONLY SPEECH THAT THE
PRESIDENT COULD GET IMPEACHED
FOR IS OBSTRUCTION OF JUSTICE.
IF THERE WAS A CONVERSATION THAT
HE HAD TO SHUT DOWN OUR
INVESTIGATION ASSOCIATED WITH A
RUSH INVESTIGATION, THAT IS
SPEECH THAT IS NOT PROTECTED
UNDER THE CONSTITUTION.
THAT IS IMPEACHABLE.
>> David: TODD, I LOVE YOUR
PODCAST, BY THE WAY.
YOU AND I HAVE DONE IT ON MY
I AGREE OR NOT.
IS THE LEFT EFFECTIVELY SHUTTING
DOWN FREE SPEECH?
>> I THINK IT DID.
WE ARE IN A VERY DANGEROUS PLACE
IN THIS COUNTRY RIGHT NOW,
DISAGREE WITH, WE ARE GOING TO
MAKE THAT HATE SPEECH.
I WANT TO GO BACK TO THIS IDEA
THAT THE DEMOCRATS ARE GOING TO
DO WHATEVER IT TAKES TO IMPEACH
THE PRESIDENT.
I BELIEVE THAT.
WE KNOW THAT UNDER THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION, THEY WEAPONIZE
THE INTERNAL REVENUE SERVICE,
>> THEY WANT AFTER BILLY GRAHAM,
SO DO I THINK IT'S POSSIBLE THAT
THEY MAY HAVE WEAPONIZE THE FBI
>> David: CHRIS, BACK TO YOU.
I WANT TO BRING SOMETHING INTO
THIS, AS A POINT OF PERSONAL
PRIDE, THAT I GOT TO MEET YOUR
FATHER A NUMBER OF TIMES.
I THINK WE HAVE A PICTURE OF THE
TWO OF US TOGETHER, THE
WHITE HOUSE CORRESPONDENTS TO
HAVE DINNER.
I THINK "SCALIA SPEAKS COME OPEN
THE BOOK CAME OUT, A GREAT WAY
TO PUT HIS VOICE INTO THE
THAT MY FATHER DELIVERED OVER
THE COURSE OF HIS CAREER.
MY COEDITOR, ED WHELAN, AND I,
REALLY WANTED TO MAKE THIS
INTERESTING AND ACCESSIBLE TO
REALLY EVERY AMERICAN INTERESTED
ABOUT THE LAW BUT THERE ARE
SPEECHES ABOUT SPORTS, HUNTING,
ABOUT THE VALUES THAT AMERICANS
HOLD DEAR, ABOUT WHAT MAKES AN
AMERICAN, THAT IT'S ABOUT
SHARING CERTAIN VALUES AND
BELIEFS IN FREEDOM AND EQUALITY.
SO IT'S A REALLY -- IT GIVES THE